resistance is
growing in a safe house in myanmar
once police saw soldiers now these men
plan to fight the forces they used to
serve
just talking to us is a huge risk
defectors can be punished with
death in hiding faces and voices
disguised for protection
they explain why they defied the junta
we were told that
we could shoot the protester if they
gather in more than five
we could arrest them and shoot them
we were ordered to shoot but we couldn't
do it
while a shoot to kill policy has never
been officially confirmed
the defectors claim they were encouraged
to open
fire
[Applause]
we contacted the junta about the
allegations in this report
it hasn't responded
my friend said if they shoot the
protesters
they will get a promotion as a reward
and be brave for being brief and
following the junior's order
[Applause]
[Music]
shoot just shoot
just my order um just how
they ordered the troops
if we did not follow the order
we will be punished
as well as the shootings the military is
accused of
other abuses
abuses of power of people of their duty
to protect people are calling soldiers
military talks and also
accusing them of rape let me tell you
yes we have seen those scenes at the
front line
i was not involved in it the officers
were calling the women
here and there and abusing them
raped as well it's happening
so now the institutions they once swore
an oath to
are the enemy they must defeat their
freedom has been sacrificed
families left behind
since the coup some protesters have
traveled to rebel areas for training
the defectors will join their fight for
democracy
those who are not familiar with the
military training
they need to learn how to use the
weapons fix them
and set up them i want to teach them
i will join this revolution till the end
i'll give my life i'll kill them
wherever i see them
so in secret they plan they train
they get strong preparing to strike
back against the generals they followed
for so long
siobhan robbins sky news in bangkok